you're a marine one of Earth's toughest
hardened in combat and trained for
action three years ago you assaulted a
superior officer for ordering his
soldiers to fire upon civilians he and
his body cast were shipped to Pearl
Harbor while you were transferred to
Mars home of the Union Aerospace
Corporation the UAC is a multiplanetary
conglomerate with radioactive waste
facilities on Mars and it's two moons
Phobos and Deimos with no action for 50
million miles your day consisted of suck
and dust and watch in restricted flicks
in the rec room
for the last four years the military UA
sees biggest supplier has used the
remote facilities on Phobos and Deimos
to conduct various secret projects
including research on interdimensional
space travel so far they've been able to
open gateways between Phobos and Deimos
throwing a few gadgets into one and
watching them come out the other
recently however the gateways have grown
dangerously unstable military volunteers
entering them have either disappeared or
being stricken with a strange form of
insanity
babbling vulgarities bludgeoning
anything that breathes
and finally suffering an untimely death
a full body explosion matching heads
with torsos to send home to the folks
became a full-time job latest military
reports state that the research is
suffering a small setback but everything
is under control a few hours ago Mars
received a garbled message from Phobos
we require immediate military support
something fraggin evil is coming out of
the gateways computer systems of gone
berserk the rest was incoherent
soon afterwards demos simply vanished
from the sky since then attempts to
establish contact with either moon have
been unsuccessful you and your buddies
the only combat trooper 50 million miles
were sent up pronto to Phobos you were
ordered to secure the perimeter of the
base while the rest of the team went
inside for several hours your radio
picked up the sounds of combat guns fire
men yelling orders screams bones crack
and then finally silence seems your
buddies are dead it's up to you things
aren't looking too good
you'll never navigate off the plan on
your own plus all the heavy weapons have
me taken by the assault team leaving you
with only a pistol if only you could get
your hands around a plasma rifle or even
a shotgun you could take down a few on
your way out whatever killed your
buddies deserves a couple of pellets in
the forehead securing your helmet you
exit the landing pod hopefully you can
find more substantial firepower
somewhere within the station as you walk
through the main entrance of the base
you hear animal-like growls echoing
throughout the distant corridors they
know you're here
there's no turning back now
you